hey everyone it's Michael here from
order flows.com and this is my
orderflows trade analysis for Monday
February 13 2017 again my name is
Michael Vos I'm the founder and Trader
at orderflows decom and today was a nice
uh a nice trending day and there's some
signs earlier in the day that the market
was going to go up but first a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures Trading
contains subst Cal risk and it's not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
training and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future
results okay so the tools used in this
presentation are the orderflows trader
the flip the U-turn and the transition
and you know I'll just pull up the the
chart here in the e- minis um you know
there's I I talk about
this situation if you want to call it
situation with the sort of setup quite
often when it when it appears and let me
find my chart real
quick I thought I had it up here but uh
anyway here it is so this is the E mini
this is A3 range chart and you know
around uh you know just ahead of the
cash open we started running up into our
highs
and this is a three- range chart so at
833 you know we had a new high we had a
Divergence okay you know 828 we had a
high didn't have a Divergence so we got
833 we got one Divergence came off a
little bit came back up hit a new high
at 838 another Divergence 841 another
Divergence this one this time though you
do have the ratio there um you know
earlier you did have the Divergence with
the ratio that's right around the cash
open not necessarily a time I'm looking
to be taking any trade and you know at
that time I'm waiting for the market to
see what's you know which way is it
going to start start
trading so we get up here 838 so you
know you know that's already the second
Divergence 841 that's another Divergence
then we get up here at uh 846 another
Divergence okay you the reason why I I'm
not interested right now here in getting
shorts cuz I know we've already put in
three divergences and we're still going
higher and when I start to see you know
three divergences in a relatively short
period of time I'm looking for the
fourth one and then you know some moves
higher
846 we got this Divergence here came off
came all the way down to uh 20 then we
started going back up got up to that
high again at uh 22 and A2 we took out
the high you know I got long I was
trying to get in here at at 2 and a half
I got a little bit impatient um I I was
looking for more of a quicker move up
but anyway you know I got out I got in
at uh two and 3/4
so you know I was long there I I was
looking for a move you know much higher
move so we've already had
four divergences you know so we had four
new highs already you know within the
first 30 40 minutes of trading and we're
coming in here we're taking out the high
again so you know I'm I'm getting long
there at uh two and 3/4 I'm just going
to draw a line here so it's a little
easier to see what my level is okay and
you know we we just hang around there
literally for the rest of the morning we
did come down here to uh 38 sorry at 938
down to
21 but you know I got some nice signs
down here that hey you know there is
support here we got this ratio bounds
low we've got this nice volume 1300
there and then you know we come back up
to the high don't quite reach there but
we're still in that area I mean then
look at this volume that's trading in
there 2,000 7,000 25,000 we come off
again come back up got another
Divergence you know this time we got
Divergence we got the ratio afterwards
and you know again I I'm still in this
position and I'm thinking hey are we
going to go higher or
what you know and this to me is normally
a bearish sign but I I know that you
know there was some very good buying
back here you know bidding buying in the
sense you know as opposed to buying up
from the offer you know people you know
working bids here 7,000
2,300 and I can see is we're coming down
here 4,000 2600 here 2,000 so you know
I'm I'm not necessarily convinced that
we're going to this is going going to be
our high of the day because there's a
lot of buying up there you know if you
know just doing the math you know off
top of my head 7,000 this is 10,000 Lots
here you know probably
another 3,000 in here
so you know maybe if this Market started
selling off we started getting down
below 21 you know I might see these guys
coming in and start selling and okay you
know the market May sell off but what
happens as we turn right back around
start making new highs again you got
some very nice volumes in here 4, 2900
3,000 these are solid buying numbers
solid volume being traded on the
bids and you know we do make that new
high you know it was interesting because
at first you know this a three- range
chart and you normally I'd be looking at
about two to three points so you know my
my first take profit would be just right
up here at 4 and 3/4 but actually you
know I was I was expecting more of a
move today you know a one-way move and
so you know I I put my offer up there at
seven and was it 7 and 3/4 I think it
was so it was about five points is what
I was looking to get out of this move
and so we hit this High we came off sort
of came back down here this my entry
price is Blue Line and again we're still
putting in some very solid numbers here
so I'm not necessarily convinced that
we're going to really sell off you know
4,000 3,000
2,000 you know then we know come back up
close to the high start coming back off
again you know we get down to one and a
half here and then look look at these
numbers here 9,000 7,000 we spent you
know close to 20 minutes almost 30 25
minutes in this bar here and I just
remember seeing all this volume and I
knew once you I said if we could get
past this to the upside we're just going
to go higher and you know because again
you you got 10,000 from earlier then you
got another you know 20,000 basically in
this period here even going back to
there and even back here you know those
7,000 you know there another 10,000 so
you know you're looking at you know
30,000 Lots being traded on the bid okay
so you know people are passively buying
it they they're happy to work bids there
people are selling them you know they're
selling it selling it 9,000 7,000 you
know once that selling gets exhausted
where's the market going to go it's
going to go up because it's not going to
go lower when the selling is exhausted
because there's buyers there that are
people that are happy to buy it
there and then what happens is it just
you know takes a while to develop again
you know this is a three- range chart
chart but again I was taking you know
more of a longer term view on this
normally a three- range chart you know
for an hour I wouldn't be in the trade
but I really thought this move had
something into it you know when when
you're looking for a trend day you want
to try and hold it as long as you can I
had my offer up here at at 7 and 3/4 I
got filled I think the high of the day
was like 29 or something like that um
you know but honestly I wasn't any
interested in in taking any other trades
that day in you know in this in this
market but you know I mean there were
some other trades to be had honestly
um you know just really quick looking at
you know some of these other
indicators uh you know this is the
U-turn this morning basically I mean you
know really from the U-turn you should
really only be looking at it around you
know 7 600 or 7 in the morning I'm not
really interested it down here at at 2:
in the morning but anyway you know I'm
not even going to count this one here so
you know say you're just looking at it
from the cash open which is about here
you have the sell which just s of go
sideways and you get a nice Buy in here
here again this this is telling you to
buy it right around that 23 area 22 and
1 half 23 area um right on up again I
didn't even notice that there was these
these cells up here but that's that's
where I got out you know that's a
fivepoint move right there this one you
know maybe you could have got something
out of it scratched it
but you know say even if you got short
in here you getting out in here and
getting long at least you know you would
have you know had a small loss on this
maybe I me again who knows um but
definitely you would have you know
gotten it all back on on that
trade
and okay the yeah the other day right
Friday I was showing a a a chart in the
euro currency with this transition
indicator and it was just giving you
know gang Buster s signals left and
right today was a bit tougher honestly
in the one on the one minute
chart um you know going back to you know
6:00 at least you know gave a buy here
which failed fail failed this one you
could have got something out of it at
9:00 um you know honestly today was a
tough day in the euro currency um you
know after 11 we're just basically you
in in a holding pattern I mean look at
that you know maybe could have got
something out of here these just you
know sideways
sideways you know up a little bit
sideways you know 2:00 you wouldn't be
looking to trade but I mean that that's
just how it goes sometimes I mean you
know not every day just going to give
you three signals four signals that are
all 100% right you know sometimes it's
going to run into a day like that where
it's just kind of you know kind of
shitty um excuse my language but uh so
anyway you know I'll show you some other
charts here this is also a eurocurrency
it's an eight range chart um just go
back to about I don't even know what's
in
here this one's you know a few of the
indicators on here this is the U-turn
the transition and the the flip
so the flip is actually the arrow the
U-turn I have set at this uh hash so you
know it gives a sell here then com
around gives you a little buy there I
mean it was it was tough this this
morning because it was just sideways
after 11:00 this is the flip and the
transition right here in this one bar at
the same time you know one bar up and
then you get a negative sign another
negative sign there and that was
it and let's see pull in another reer
currency chart yeah again I could show
you all the charts but uh I just want
you to see you know the euro currency
this is the transition today there's
just this one on the 987 tick chart here
I if you could see that 987 tick um you
know so you know basically you
know wasn't much movement you know after
basically after 10:00 it was really dead
in the
water um
you know just really quick crude
oil on the 987 tick chart it was
interesting say the least uh where are
we we just going back
here um I mean there's nothing earlier
but uh when we run into this time here
at uh you know 8:00 gave have a buy here
which failed failed pretty quick but you
know it came back with another
buy you know the second one worked a
little bit it wasn't a big
move
you know but again you know this one
failed here but then this next one here
you know you could have got something
out of it not much it was only about a
10 tick move before you got this cell
here which you know started to go down
but then it came right back up in this
one bar you know which if you're not out
probably would have stopped you out you
know but that's why I should you know
look to Trail your stops but then this
signal here this one at 8 uh like around
850 the cell you know somewhere around
5315 and that was it lights out
you know it went all the way down make a
little smaller so from
5315 you know down below you know
5300 you know and then we just hang
around this 5280 to
5290 95 area until the
close in the night session we're trading
here at 02 right now but you know this
this put you on the right side for
basically the rest of the day with very
little very little ouch sorry very
little
um you know pullbacks you know you had
this little one initially but after that
it was just you know got below 53 dou
and stayed
below and you know one other couple
other charts real
quick um where am I it's mini D I'm just
look want to pull it in
here okay I've been talking about this
mini doll
contract recently and you know this
morning started out difficult you know
from 8:30 if you're trading mini da
trade it when the Dow is open don't be
messing around with it at at 4 in the
morning you know 840 just before you got
a sell here which failed right off the
bat I remember looking at these
things I was in my mini trade pretty
much most of the
morning and then here got a sell okay
got a little bit of something here you
know from 30 down to you know 25 but
again it was very quiet you know as as
far as when you'd get a sell signal and
here you got a sell which didn't work
out so you know you got basically you
know two losers one scratch this one
sort of didn't really work out either
you know it's debatable if that you know
if you would have really made anything
or you would have you know taken some
heat but again you know if you're
getting short at 40 you know it trades
up to
45 you know if you're using a five tick
stop yeah you'd be stopped out you know
if you got an eight tick stop you know
you wouldn't be um and then later uh
10:00 we had nice Buy Signal here at the
35 area you know it trades all the way
up to 50 55 got another Buy Signal this
one didn't work out you know but you
should have I mean you wouldn't be
looking to get long hair I mean ideally
you got long hair so you'd still be long
then it just sort of Peters out you know
so you know maybe you could have got
something from 35 up to around the the
Area um you know then just sort of you
know sells off comes back up here you
get another Buy Signal here up into the
sell signal you know who knows maybe 5
10 ticks 12:00 you get this Buy in here
it does come down against you again you
know this is the area around you know 62
or 60 62 I think it was you know it
trades down to five or
56 again you know I don't know you know
if you're using a very a five tick stop
you would have been stopped out okay but
anyway later you get a nice Buy Signal
here
again you know this one I don't think
you would have been stopped out you're
only talking two or three ticks it
pulled down against you um you know and
then it trades all the way up to you
know 95 so you know whatever call this
80 you know up to 90 could have got
something out of it and just sort of
hangs there did come back down to 80 you
know 80 back to 90 so I mean hopefully
you could have got something out of that
but um you know later in the
day we got this nice Buy Signal here 145
146 you know basic telling you get short
here at around the 80 level and then it
just trades down down down
down never even comes back up to 80 and
you get a Buy Signal here just before
the cash close got to be careful um I
mean you can trade around there but you
know if you did you you were rewarded so
you know this move from 80 down to you
know the 65 area I'm not saying down
here at 60 um you know definitely down
in here you know maybe 70 okay and then
look at this this you get this nice move
sometimes you get these nice moves right
after the cash close and look at that it
just moves straight up from you know the
60 area all the way up to the 90 area
where we closed in right now in the in
the evening session we're trading at uh
87 so just real quick in the bonds in
case you guys are wondering if there's
anything not really um I remember
looking you I had this Divergence here
at 8:00 then we have another Divergence
here got a zero print we've got a
stacked
imbalance you know got a nice strong
Delta but you know these numbers you
know they're kind
of ideally I like to see above a
thousand at least one of these numbers
but these are chunky these are chunky I
was remember looking at it thinking okay
maybe we could uh move higher S&P are
still up near the highs which you know
is is uh usually not a good sign you
know if I'm looking I don't like to be
long bonds and long
S&P but uh yeah I remember looking at
this and sort of thinking okay let's see
how it comes back and then right in the
next bar you know you got two imbalances
a down candle and I was thinking ah okay
well we're probably going to look for
the low still we did make the low just
before 10:00 we got a
Divergence this is the Delta scalper
given a buy here actually and you know
again but other than that I really
didn't really see anything very solid in
the in the order flow I mean we did
rally up from there but it was just you
know it's kind of like a
nothing dramatic nothing
dramatic all right so thanks for
watching this video to learn more about
trading software used in this
presentation and how you can add
orderflow to your trading how you can
profit from orderflow visit my website
www. orderflows
docomo posted up on on my channel
here recently within the last week for
the flip the U-turn in transition each
video is about an hour long but uh you
know these
are orderflow tools to read the order
flow for you which which will make it
easier for for you as a Trader you see
them on a normal bar chart but they run
on an orderflow chart as well I just
have them on there so you can see it a
lot easier and a lot
cleaner but um again you know any
questions just go to my website
orderflows decom and you know you you'll
find a lot of information on there so
thanks for watching this and hope to see
you on the
inside